what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are gonna do a first time watching
today for the animated movie starring a comedian I
absolutely adore Will Ferrell Megamind I've never
seen this I saw the trailer for this years
ago don't remember Jack about that trailer
but remember being like I'm gonna watch it and
I never watched it with that in mind ladies and
Gentlemen please go ahead and leave a like that
would be extremely appreciated also uh full length
Reaction watch alongs where you sync up with
your own copy of Megamind I'm actually gonna
watch this off Netflix right now is available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page I just want
to say a special thank you I'm really grateful to
everyone who has supported and joined our patreon
we were one of those channels last Saturday
where there was a glitch on YouTube completely
lost all monetization even had a new video go
up that I spent like several hours working on
no monetization on it so for those who pledge
from that video thank you thank you very much
patreon's literally saved us more ways than once
so thank you guys and we're going to continue my
hero Academia uh sometime this week and we cover
a bunch of other shows exclusively over there
with the reaction that's watching lungs included
all right enough enough talking let's get to it
went to jail lost the girl of my dreams and
got my butt kicked pretty good oh that's right
falling to my death oh wow my end starts at
the beginning the very beginning like birth
like birth okay I came from what you might call
a broken home literally broken hmm oh it's got a
Superman story you are destined I didn't quite
hear that last part but it sounded important
that was the day I met Mr Curry Two Shoes
would this be what I was destined for
a dream life filled with luxury oh you
dick a much different fate waited me
what a place that taught me the
differences between right and wrong
it's given an opportunity to better myself
through learning like other prisoners just
kept the alien he had already amassed
a gigantic Army of soft-headed groupies
oh he bought their affections with
Showmanship extravagant Gifts of deliciousness
it's like if Lex Luthor was misunderstood
he just wants love
that's when I learned a very hard lesson
evil is sent to quiet time in the corner
so fitting in wasn't really an option he's just
misunderstood no matter how hard I tried I was
always the odd man out oh poor Brainiac if
I was the bad boy the going to be the boy of
nice our battles quickly got more elaborate he
would win some I would almost win others metro map
defender of matrosity is
that the one Brad Pitt voices
I really like the animation and this
any chance you could give me the time
oh looks like you're gonna miss it by
several thousand years that's JK Simmons
happy Metro man
I like the earlier era flare of this this is
RR wow okay the stuff they make you read
on air that's unfreaking believable it's
crazy I wrote that piece myself what I was
trying to say was I can't believe that in
our modern society they let like actual art
get onto the news sounds like Jonah Hill not
love we're not in love I'm not saying I love
you hey I love you whatever poor Jimmy Olsen
yeah the animation has that like old school
Flair of Espionage to it with comic stripped
whoa what are you doing guys it's me it's the
war you were right I'll always be a villain
all right put your hands in the air
I get Homeland revives from this guy
Despicable Me as well away quick to work
who is this I was just Roxanne predictable
predictable you're alligators yes
juvenile shocking off khaki oh scary in it
what's this one doing okay the spider's new
fighter oh even the smallest bite from
arachnus deathicus will instantly paralyzed
foreign
Don't Panic Roxy
oh how fun Metro man approaching sir
it was all part of his plan
hold on a second are they gonna pull some
like other guys fliparoo and Metro man loses
you were in the real Observatory did you did
you smart thinking you've Fallen right into
my trap you can't trap Justice it's an
idea a belief of even the most heartfelt
belief can be corroded over time Justice is a
non-corrosive metal but Metals could be melted
by this it's revenge and it's best served
cold but it can be easily reheated in the
microwave of evil well I think your warranty
is about to expire maybe I got an extended one
but as if Metro man can withstand the
full concentrated power of the sun fire
this is embarrassing could someone
you love all people know no promotion your
Dark Gift has finally paid off it it has
but obviously lined with copper yeah so sir
copper trades my Powers your weakness is copper
oh no oh [__] he won oh
that's a fascinating setup
what's the movie about that
what no way I did it
what are you gonna have to live for now
that's a really interesting setup
good for you man
I can't swear can't swear can't swear
oh just look did you think this day would ever
come no way no not never never in a million I mean
now that Mr shoes is out of the way I can
have everything I want and there's no one to
stop it oh dude but you have no purpose
now what's a villain without his hero
ouch
no you can't is this gonna get
like really dark think about it
at all yet we have nothing oh yeah you'd be
empty man it's just too easy now you gotta
earn it we did it right then why do I feel so
Melancholy melancholy you should come over I got
a DJ rented a bouncy house made a gallon of dip
it's gonna be sick I don't really feel like being
around a bunch of people no no that's the best
part it'll just be like you and me creepy I did
hire a wedding photographer that's just in case we
were like something crazy happening if we wanted
a picture of it like maybe we should have this
for like ever like a memory you know um I'm gonna
pass oh this Roxanne girl is just treated with
so much disregard kidnapped creepily hit it on
is there a way to resurrect him
or create a new hero or something I had
had the illiteracy beam food that's stupid
you know I never had the chance to say goodbye
it's good that we have this time now
you know before I destroy the place
Holy balls
hello is someone there we're having
the walls and ceiling removed wow that
sounds like quite the renovation I guess
I'll um catch a ride down with you then
if only the world had a reset button I've looked
into the reset button besides is impossible
didn't know you had feelings are you
okay just general feelings as long
as I believe someone is going to stand
up to mega mind you really think so yeah
Heroes aren't born they're made oh shoot he is
going to make one I'm going to give someone I
don't know who yet Metro Man's powers I'm going
to train that someone to become atrocities new
hero Mr Miyagi it's his DNA from this we'll
extract the source of metroman's awesome
power what if you end up making him like
a bad guy you must find a suitable subject
someone Noble heart and Minds who puts the
welfare of others above their own Jimmy Olsen
I certainly building in Metro city
with a fake Observatory on the roof
creation of science what oh no not you Roxanne
no I was just yelling at my mother's urn
Roxanne whoa oh I better take the lead this way
looks exciting no it says Exit uh which
is the abbreviation for exciting right
and that code said there's a braver you know the
whole point of a code is code just do it a code
let him go or or what or I'm gonna find out what
this weird looking gun does I'll just go get him
I'm happy you happy you've never is your
strengths too much um I work out let go it's fine
you're gonna you're gonna turn him
no no no there's there could
be evil in that guy down
you were right about that door being exciting yeah
anyone but Metro man stand up to him like
that oh my God I better take him home
oh no this is bad that was weird for everybody
because you accidentally hugged him instead of me
what's happening to the real Bernard
no no makeup to fall for her or has he
always been in love with her who is this man
what's her his name's Hal Stewart he's 28
years old no criminal record apparently this
man hasn't accomplished anything not yet I
don't like this at all this is no mistake
that is a really funny physical bit
it doesn't look such a pill minion the
Potter couldn't ask for finer clay I like
how they kept Mega mine with boyish eyes
holy crap what's going on
easy my child who are you I
sent you to this planet to teach you about Justice
I am your father so you're like my
space dad yeah I'm like you spaced that
I'm your space stepmom
I had some work done recently is this some
kind of dream this is a dream come true
unfathomable power what kind of power
unfathomable it's on without fathom
to be atrocities new hero and battle the Super
Genius of Megamind it's a great Marlon brand
new impression it may take months for
you to come to grips I wasn't finished
yeah this is a terrible idea
foreign
and brilliantly told by the
way okay now you tell one
I never heard you laugh
no this is so awkward
oh cool it's like a Mario Donkey Kong level
for everything I'm sad that we didn't
this is so bad this is Icky hey what's a t
stand for Titan Titan what's that supposed
to mean I could be a villain's name do you have
someone special in your life how there's this
really really good looking one I've got my
eye on currently that's gonna turn him evil
oh God it was a creep such a creep just a few
black mama nicely done you've Fallen
it's actually a great shot who you
that's the point of lying the
oh my sole purpose in life is to look after you
well I don't need you to look after me but he's
no you don't need me let me
make it clear minion loves you
I'll just pack my thing and go
code my thing and go well good
bye
poor minion wait a minute
what do you see Titan what how'd she
do that my super ears are burning
and I brought some flowers didn't know what you
liked so I just grabbed you know all of them you
stole them thought maybe we could go for a little
Flight Around Town get to know each other first
I should just rescue you a few times before
we get all romantic whoops it's our creepy
wowza one you almost died
horrifying to do to her cute clothes I'm a little
crazy about you who are you the
animation is pretty cool though
great
you are Disturbed this isn't right
it's Titan it's Titan not how
oh my goodness thousands of civilians on the
ground floor just died glass shards perishing
many families your hair looks exciting not the
only exciting development of the night how'd you
make it down I'm sure we'll get to the bottom of
who's kicking who's butt but in the meantime each
other's company I'm sorry to being normal hell
of us you can just drop the topic of conversation
after that horrifying incident let's say I was
bald and had the complexion of of a popular
primary color would you still enjoy my company
you don't judge a book by its cover or person
from the outside oh oh no you judge them based
on their actions well that seems kind of petty
oh my God this is so bad
this is so bad
don't look yet ow this poor woman
has so mistreated this whole movie
that reveal came a little bit
earlier than I expected you actually
made a care about you why are you so evil tricking
me it was pretty messed up I don't believe this
oh mess the visitors get up a
pillow pepper this is conflicting
manipulating the whole situation
I don't think it's okay
gone man
looks like Sinestro okay Titan it's
time to go down the style Todd it's
gonna be doing some evil [__]
you're gonna become the good guy
foreign what is Titan doing were
you even planning on showing up
what's this oh my God he's gone fulfilling
I only took the gig to get the girl and it
turns out Roxanne doesn't want anything to
do with uxar having dinner and making googly
eyes at some intellectual dweep oh you're the
good guy I do something bad and you come and
get me that's why I created you Odo I'm your
space dad also the intellectual dweeb dating
Roxanne bring me to Justice oh God now I missed
it oh God you did not prepare yourself for this
you fell for the oldest evil trick
in the book you little blue twerp
generation is so awesome oh my God oh my
gosh right in the crotchy back and forth
okay look I'm not sure where to go with that
here's what's the space
time making a fool out of me
game over
oh my goodness
what have you given birth to megabyte
guess what Buster Brown oh no he
can withstand his catchy foreign
thank you Titan has freed us
more like Under New Management
this is so bad
house ah I remember when he wore that let me try
to stay focused here yes of course right focused
hey come over and look at this what is it what
did you find this glass has ice cubes in it yes
that's what happens when water gets cold no what
I'm saying is odd that the ice hasn't melted yet
no way hey
you jerk I did not see that coming I'm alive but
we we saw your skeleton you were dead are you a
ghost Copper's not his real weakness we we had
done this same silly charade our entire lives
I tried to get my mind off how I was feeling
each and every citizen of Metro had something
I didn't a choice ever since I can remember
I've always had to be what the city wanted
me to be it's like an anime characters get bored
copper brains my Powers your weakness is copper
oh you dick finally free to
get in touch with my two power
granted you have talent but there's a
Madman out there you know little buddy
there's a Yin for every Yang if there's
bad good will rise up against it good we
AK layer grab some ray guns
come on man unless someone comes
to our age soon all may be lost
thousands have already fled the city in a mass
Exodus French men should just wear a mask you
know the Megamind I knew would never have run
from a fight even when he knew he had absolutely
no chance of winning that is true it was your
best quality he has always had this the city
one hour don't keep me waiting oh you
perv Warden wouldn't I am sorry what
to make Roxanne pay for my wrongdoings
apology accepted what
this city will never financially recover
from all this damage you're living a fan
there is no Easter Bunny
there is no tooth fairy in
it
wow what an entrance you're a villain all right
foreign
wow
this is crazy
they're back in the air Mega month foreign
no ah the perception looks like
there's only one loose end now
oh he's returned my death was greatly
exaggerated so you're the punk I've heard about
I'm so proud of you
minion what surprise
he's the real hero Megamind no way
you know what's good for you Titan
you'll stay out of atrocity you got it for good
but he could come back and now all
the people believe he's still around
there's so many gaps in this planet
oh never mind okay everyone will see the truth
but there's only one person I know who calls this
town atrocity you're not gonna
be laughing for long yikes
I'm really interested in this
I made you a hero you did the
full thing all by yourself
oh no you're gonna kill him no matter what side
you're on you're always the
loser that's just not true
warm it up again
enjoy your flight
exciting music so this is how it
ends ah yes normally I'd chalk this
up to my last glorious failure but not today Holo
smart
thing about bad guys they always
lose oh he's not a bad guy anymore
you won well I finally had a reason to win you
Ah that's touching that's some touch and [__]
we've had a lot of adventures together
you and I we have minion we won today
oh oh I'm going I think this this
is it I'm going going far away
what a drama queen you know
I'm feeling much better now
back to positive feedback
that was brilliant
you're pretty good in white
there we go
sorry my friend way to go little
buddy I knew he hadn't been
defender of Metro City probably also
should have rebuilt Metro man statue
oh who has the answer but
not to tell you once again
that's the answer right now just
to tell you what to get who's bad
that was awesome I thought that was that was
Tina Fey Jesus why could I not put it together
where's the Goddamn sequel for this movie
okay apparently there's that there is a scene
oh this is day of my entire life oh no worries
I forgot about him that was awesome let's talk
about it I thought that was great sincerely that
was awesome all righty well guys um I mean this
sincerely I thought that was amazing it was one
of those movies that felt like it got better as
it kept going you know and he often don't get
to really say that about too many films and
sometimes even with animated movies you're like
ass there's parts of the middle trunk I feel a
little bit off but as it progressed it got funnier
and it got him more emotional and it got cooler
and I mean what more could you want from a film
like this in some ways I feel like mega mega
mind almost to make a man in some ways I feel like
Megamind is a little bit ahead of its time because
this corner of Netflix came out in 2010 and I
feel like now if it came out it probably would
have been more appreciated because you know one of
the stories I heard circulating around this film
is that it wasn't a box office box office success
yet the critical and on interception was not bad
it was actually uh fairly well received but it's
obviously had more of a Resurgence perhaps in the
past like year to two and it's a movie that's been
requested uh for the real rejects for quite some
time and uh then it was like top 10 on Netflix one
of the time I'm filming this I was like you know
what yeah let's make some time to watch this film
and I see why it's garnered so much appreciation
you know like when you got shows like boys and
Invincible things like that now on on the air
which which dealt so much with like deconstruction
of superheroes then you got something like this
where you know that was just the beginning of
the comic book superhero movie boom that we
now have that has dominated the industry when you
look at what they do here it is such a wonderful
deconstruction like so many ways the plot feels um
you know what if Lex Luthor had defeated Superman
and it even deals with that classic conversation
of like can there be the villain without the hero
you know that often often debate that you do
here was running Lex Luthor and Superman than
you do here with like Batman and Joker you know
the great hero versus the great uh villain uh so
I I think like in terms of honoring the superhero
genre of the comic book movie genre I think it did
an incredible job and their the animation itself
I think is ridiculously phenomenal like this is
12 years old but damn it looks so good there were
still so many sequences especially in its actions
whenever tracking shots that we're doing there
were so many sweeping moments that I was in awe
of I could not believe how this looks ju this
if this had come out this year I would still be
saying the same thing they might have fine-tuned a
few more things sure but for the most part hurt I
still think it looks Flawless it looks amazing and
like the way the city is realized like yeah you
do get vibes of something like The Incredibles
but it does feel like it's doing its own thing
and the way they fleshed out the characters I
mean first off The Voice work is incredible it
is really really really phenomenal Voice work
because the way they match their expressions
with like everyone is so perfectly cast even down
to something like a Brad Pitt who I know has been
making the headlines recently for all the greatest
greatest news in the world but Brad Pitt is the
kind of name that like I I love the performer Brad
Pitt don't get me wrong but it is the kind of name
that when I hear Brad Pitt in a voice over role
like they only got cast and he's famous probably
still the case but even he was like perfect for
for this role he did an exceptional job but Will
Ferrell is MegaMind I think the intentional choice
to constantly maintain that hurt Lost Boy quality
in the performance in the Expressions make mega
mind the villainous appearance on the outset
but keep those like sympathetic Lost Boy eyes
within the character from beginning to end help
complement the performance so well like you you
really feel like you you know this character so
early on as just this boy who just feels like
he's trying to find something great and feels
hurt and wants love ultimately he's just that
character who really wants love and he's not as
bad as he probably sets out to be but I love the
kickoff point I just love that kickoff point of
and you know Lex The Lex Luthor type villain
defeating Superman and then the twists and turns
that it did along the way like honestly there were
some things I was able to sort of semi predict of
that that seemed a bit obvious to me of it looks
like you might actually defeat him and then it
made me go what's this plot gonna be and then it
took an interesting Turn For What the plot would
be of having Mega might have this existential
crisis and then ultimately trying to produce
a hero because he can't feel fulfilled without
it's like trying to create some type of external
circumstances to fill fill that void within him
and then of course when he starts creating Titan
in the way they set up Titan is so well because
they have the Hal character played by Jonah Hill
again wonderfully cast perfectly cast for it you
have the Hal character um initially he does come
across like a little bit creepy but they don't go
too full board creepy because you're like ah he's
kind of a little shy dweebish guys trying to get
the pretty you know girl who who's definitely in
like a higher chair category than him he's trying
to get her but you know he's not ultimately gonna
land her so he does come across creepy but it's
also rooted in such insecurity and that's what
they do with both of their characters both with
Megamind and with um Hal is they make them both so
insecure that you feel pity towards them and even
with Hal but they plant the seeds just right so
by the time he does Turn full villain and the way
they are teasing that he there's a villain within
him waiting to come out was really well executed
it's this like percolating villain within this guy
and I thought it was great so by the time he does
does turn and the stakes are that high and then
with the twists and turns the ones I really didn't
see coming was that Metro man was still alive and
and the way they've revealed that was really funny
and I like the again it's sort of an introspective
take that they had with Metro man of going through
the motions you know and it's like similar you
you do one of the great things that I think comic
book properties can often do is draw the parallels
between hero and villain and with this film you
know you do have MegaMind who after defeating
Metro man or at least thinks he does he's going
through the motions and then he needs something
different to feel more fulfilled and then Metro
man was already going through that same path
already he was just ahead of Megamind on that curb
and I like that it led to a moment of by allowing
Mega Man to think he defeated him in the path
that it goes on I I thought it was so touching for
Metro man to be hidden amongst the crowd and to
cheer him on like yeah you made the turn because
they could have just kept battling for ages but
the thing that led Mega Man Down Mega minded down
this how many times have I said Mega Man during
this discussion about the center more than once
the thing that let Megamind down the path of
becoming a hero was Metro man removing himself
from the pitcher I think it's pretty cool I think
there's something like more there's more Nuance
to this picture than I imagined like walking into
this I hear the voice cast I hear Will Ferrell's
in it I hear Jonah Hill Brad Pitt I just expected
a funny film I wasn't expecting something that
was going to be filled with wonder that was going
to have like sweeping animation like I bet there
would be good animations Dreamworks Animation so
I expect a good animation but I wasn't expecting
something that would leave me in awe over what I
was witnessing also Tina Fey is Roxanne excellent
oh my God just another great character she
is treated like that type of you know female
character where the mangocatter everyone wants
her and everyone's kind of mistreating her
doesn't really make an awareness about that but
by the end of the film I you know I I can't help
but I you know I can't deny it I was like you
know what the friendship and chemistry that is
formed I do like that they did not end this with
Megamind and Roxanne ultimately ending up together
like when I thought this movie had a real good
complexity to me was when the breakup moment did
occur because that's when I was feeling all the
feelings I was like man no Roxanne's totally right
to be feeling this like this is manipulative this
is kind of disgusting and horrid yet this movie is
awesome having me feel very very bad for Megamind
at the same time because you really get him so I
wasn't expecting to walk into a movie where the
characters were as fleshed out as they are like
they're really well done I even really cared about
the relationship between Megamind and Minion you
know like that I just watched DC League of Super
Pets and I would I would certainly rank this movie
above that one and you know they had it's kind of
a similar thing you know instead of is Superman
was left off with crypto after being departed from
Kryptonite they get that right after being depart
from Krypton and here you know he's left with
minion as his little companion the one to always
be this unconditional Force for him so I think
the way they flesh out that relationship was also
really well done maybe not one of the most nuanced
ones maybe one that's played a little bit more
for humor but by the time they reunite I I thought
this movie was just balanced really well it didn't
Teeter too much I mean over the top comedy for
me and it didn't Teeter too much and go into some
like dark nuanced territory where it lost sight
of the kind of family Vibe it's actually aiming
for I thought it kept everything at the right
pitch and kept it exhilarating and entertaining
so yeah for what I want from my animated movies I
thought the animation was excellent I thought the
voiceover work was good I thought there was better
commentary than I was actually anticipating I do
feel like this movie in a lot of ways was ahead
of its time I think if this had come out now it'd
probably be much more appreciated for what it was
ultimately setting out to do who did Ben Stiller
voice he voice Bernard what I have the IMDb pulled
up in front of me right now oh that's cool anyway
yeah and you know like yeah the riffs on the
Superman tail I think are really fun and uh
I don't know what more can you say I feel
like everything was sort of firing on all
cylinders here and it was also a really funny
time so yeah amazing superhero film and one
that I'm glad is at least being appreciated
now and according to here they have like a
a Netflix series in development that's cool um oh
no peacock it's Series in development okay gotcha
well I wonder if the voice cast is returning you
know is this intentional there were Parts about
um what you may call it uh Metro man's performance
that's semi reminded me of Elvis Presley did you
kind of get these guys kind of get the same Vibe
that's what I felt like it was and JK Simmons is
Warden oh yeah I love the old comic strip flare to
this and uh I did find it like very very heartfelt
with some good lessons to be learned too and it
was a believable turn for making mine like I like
the oh there's one thing I was sort of craving
from this movie is a tad bit of of that little
extra punch this is a really big like this is a
nitpick I I am craving a tad bit of that little
extra punch of awareness of some of the situations
kind of like with Roxanne of how she was treated
but also you know it's like Mega Minds being
touted as this Hero at the end of the day but
I'm like really what he did was solve a problem
he caused so all this destruction of Titan and all
this other chaos and everything like while he had
good intentions it certainly backfired and turned
into a catastrophe putting all these people in
In Harm's Way in danger and maybe some lives are
actually cost but he's being looked at as like
this great phenomenal hero when really it could
have been somewhere maybe like even like a some
joke that just acknowledged like well he actually
did cause all this you know so that a little bit
of awareness I think would have just been that
little Added Touch a little extra spice for me but
if they did too much awareness throughout it would
have pulled me out but yeah guys um that's pretty
straightforward thoughts here I thought it was an
excellent film and I thought it was really funny
and uh wonderfully voiced wonderfully animated
great music and I even like the needle drops they
chose I thought actually complemented the piece
well sometimes with these animated Properties
or any film in general certain needle drops just
feel like they're doing it because they have
the license too and they could throw some cool
nostalgic music in there but I thought the needle
drops they had in here were perfectly accustomed
for every scene so then that one little craving
that I had I thought this was great yeah I had a I
had a blast with this one so ladies and gentlemen
leave your thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that Bell thank you to all who followed
us on patreon and hey let's end this with a pic
Tyler Hague I just wanted to hop here really quick
and say thank you for being the amazing gracious
man that you are like I'll be honest sometimes
I get so busy that I don't take enough time to
perhaps go through my social media messages
or go through the patreon messages you know
once in a while I was like usually a few times a
month I'm like I'm gonna dedicate like an hour to
doing this whenever I come across yours there's
a part of me that does feel a little bit bad for
not getting back to you earlier enough because
you've been with us for such a long time you've
gifted us with many amazing things and you've
just been this gentle giving spirit this entire
time you've been with us and you're you're like
the kind of reflection I I hope a lot of our
audience can be like there's something inspiring
about the sincere nature that you possess so
thank you for being a thank you for Lending
us your spirit and thank you for being who
you are because I don't take that part
about you for granted like there's not
a single negative thing I can say about you
you're there's something very beautiful about
whenever I get to interact with you and I'm
whenever I do take the time to finally get
back to people and especially when I
can take the time to reply to you I
I always feel good at the same time to be able to
interact with you because it's nice to be reminded
of folks like you out there who help support us
so I mean when I say I love you buddy thank you